there is someone else on the other side
of that me or another me there has got
to be a way out
there's no telling what could happen
well so so I could tell you that I owe
you one
the advice you gave it really helped me
get through to Allegra it's very
insightful almost parental
you're going somewhere that I'm just
saying if you ever want to talk like I
said I owe you one
and uh I'm a very good listener
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my video for the flash
season 6 episode 12 trailer video in a
bunch of big stuff that they revealed is
coming later this season like Wally West
gorilla grodd the death of the Speed
Force arc from the flash rebirth comics
so we'll break it all down they even
talked about what's going on with
reverse flash I know lots of big
questions about reverse flash so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing a flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
let me know what you want them to do
with perverse flash when they bring him
back
so we'll just break this down top-10
style and I will address what happened
in last night's episode because I didn't
do a traditional episode video I just
really was not happy with what they did
in the episode he's got a way to
ridiculous especially like the last 10
minutes with Amunet black and gold faces
character just way way too over-the-top
and it felt kind of like a filler
episode because they're having so much
big stuff that's coming up they probably
wanted to save money by not using a lot
of special effects anytime you don't see
the flash running around a lot like
Barry's just standing around and his
normal street clothes it's usually
because they want to save money because
it's really expensive to have him doing
a bunch of big stuff on screen but it
was basically meant to be a Valentine's
Day episode there was a big WTF twist at
the end though so number 9 WTF
nashville's hallucinating earth to
harrison wells at the end of the episode
a lot of big questions after crisis on
Infinite Earths about what happened with
the multiverse because there was a whole
sort of post-credit scene where they
were setting up the concept of earth
Prime and all the combined earths but
they also showed us a bunch of other
Earth's in the multiverse then cut to
the flash season 6 episode 10 and it
opens with Cisco talking about how
there's no more multiverse like why
doesn't Cisco know that there's a
multiverse what's going on so the
producers like Marc Guggenheim the
people that worked on crisis on Infinite
Earths into showrunners for all the
different shows just said that most of
the characters don't know that the
multiverse came back so they only think
that everyone's dead so when they say
that like Jesse quick and earth to
Harrison Wells died during crisis in
episode 10 they just think that they
died really good example is a gorilla
grodd episode that's coming up that I'll
talk about in a second it implies we
might see Jesse quick comeback this
season the whole earth - Harrison wells
Nashville scene just see
more like him hallucinating him
foreshadowing the eventual revealed that
the multiverse is back in earth to
Harrison wells is alive and well this is
whole running story line with Nash wells
this season about the guilt that he
feels over a crisis and being the pariah
character it has the Allegra character
is basically a doppelganger of his
daughter who he's now treating like his
surrogate daughter so we'll see where
they take that but number 8 WTF all the
Sue did need trailer footage so if you
couldn't tell obviously this is a lot of
episode 12 trailer footage for next week
the title of that episode is a girl
called Sue is in sue did neat they're
finally introducing her in a big way on
the show
elongated man wasn't really in this
week's episode but apparently next week
he will find her in a really big way she
was thought to be a missing socialite
initially but then they found out that
she was connected to black hole and was
trying to investigate them herself
before she disappeared
the last we heard of it was right before
a crisis on Infinite Earths ramped up
and they only just started doing the
real black hole storyline using the new
mirror master company McCulloch tech so
the way they're pitching their TV show
version of sued didney is that she'll
also be something of a gumshoe like
ralph and she'll take him on this big
case that they try to investigate what's
going on with black hole I think they're
just trying to make the character a
little more interesting if you've read
any of sue did nice storyline in the
comics there isn't a whole lot going on
with her other than her relationship
with elongated man that's usually how
she's presented like they're deeply and
loved together in this about it she had
a really tragic story line during
identity crisis of course they're not
going to do the identity crisis
storyline I feel like most people
understand that it's just way too WTF
for the CW to do something like that if
you've never read it it's pretty
traumatic so you can actually check it
out in the comics if you really want to
torture yourself
number seven WTF there's all the footage
with iris stuck in the mirror dimension
with the new version of mirror master
Ava
McCulloch we'll see if she winds up
having a Scottish accent because
obviously that version of mere master is
supposed to be Scottish so number six
the new version of mirror master it
seems like based on the episode footage
last week the post-credits tag in what's
happening in the trailer footage mirror
master is also trapped inside the mirror
dimension for some reason it probably
has something to do with black hole and
the research she was doing there's this
weird doppelganger effect that's going
on like there's this alternate version
iris that's now living out a life with
Barry on the other side of the mirror
who seems like a twisted darker version
of iris for some reason that's not
something from the comics that's
something that the TV show is inventing
the mirror dimension is a very big
comic-book place but when you enter the
comic book mirror dimension you just get
trapped there you don't generate some
kind of weird doppelganger or anything
like that so there's just something that
the TV show is doing the way they're
pitching this version of mirror master
though I think is gonna be a bit of a
twist like she won't show up as a
villain the first time and it might have
something to do with the doppelganger
I'm sure there'll be a bunch of deep
cuts for a mere master in the comics but
they've already done her mirror gun so
I'm sure at some point she will start
using the mirror gun if she makes it out
of the mirror dimension number five WTF
the next big villain so I'm assuming
that whoever the next big villain is it
will also connect to black hole and all
the fake god speeds that we saw at the
beginning of the season seriously
episode 1 some of you've been asking
since then what's going on with God
speed they haven't explained that since
the first episode the way they explain
that opening scene is that the
signatures made it seemed like they were
coming from the future at some points so
implies there's gonna be some sort of
flash time-travel villain showing up or
at least someone from the future and
they're only a couple of flash villains
from the future that we haven't seen
this season that includes abracadabra
who hasn't been around in a couple
seasons he was on the very first page of
Cisco's new pokedex of flash rogues so
that makes me think that they're gonna
bring him back sometime soon gotta catch
em all gotta catch all those flash rogue
Pokemon
there's also reverse flash who's the
other most famous flash villain who's a
time traveler they said he's coming back
later this season I know there's a lot
of reverse flash WTF questions because
they totally cut him out a crisis on
Infinite Earths and they spent six years
hyping up reverse flash during crisis on
Infinite Earths since the pilot episode
I'm sure when he comes back eventually
before the end of the season there'll be
some jokes about why he wasn't there
when clearly in the finale in season 5
he told Barry he'd be back for the next
crisis number 4 WTF the producers of
crisis on Infinite Earths which are some
of the showrunners of the other TV shows
like arrow the flash Supergirl legends
of tomorrow did explain why they didn't
include reverse flash in crisis
according to them they didn't want to be
shackled to the story that the people on
the flash
TV show created in the first episode in
that pilot episode with a future
newspaper they kind of wanted to ignore
that because the people that created
that in the flash pilot episode aren't
working on the flash TV show anymore all
those writers have gone on to other TV
shows I got a little upset when he said
that like I feel like they were clearly
setting something up and then it's
completely sidestepped it so hopefully
when they bring him back they'll have
some clever way of tying off that big
plot hole like Oh remember that thing
that we were saying was gonna happen for
six years we just decided not to do that
but number three WTF this will actually
make you a little bit happier the
gorilla grodd episode that they're doing
so they usually do gorilla grodd episode
at least once per season this year it's
gonna be episode 13 so it's gonna happen
in two weeks
Barry's supposed to be experimenting
with the Speed Force remember how his
hand gave all that weird energy after a
crisis when Diggle showed up he'll be
running an experiment that'll
accidentally put him in gorilla grodd's
path and expect a big fight but anchor
ill across surprise surprise will want
his help and they'll have to team up to
defeat so levar who apparently is evil
on earth Prime
the title of the Grodd episode is Grodd
friended me which is a parody of the
title of the show that the actress who
plays Jessie quick is on now called God
friended me a lot of people expecting
some sort of Jessie quick cameo
hopefully explaining more about what's
going on with the earth - Harrison wells
hallucinations that Nash wells is
happening in what's going on with the
multiverse number two WTF is the big
Wally West episode that's coming up
that'll be episode 14 I don't think his
costume is gonna be too different but
they did say that he's gonna be a very
different version of the character much
wiser much more in tune with the Speed
Force the more spiritual version of
Wally West that we saw in the comics way
back during the Mark Waid era number one
WTF is the death of the Speed Force
storyline which is also connected to the
Wally West stuff so if you haven't been
reading the flash comics the last couple
of years they just did a storyline last
season called the death of the Speed
Force so obviously they're doing a
version of that on the TV show that'll
probably be a little bit different the
comics introduced the idea that there
are other versions of that with
different powers that they grant people
there's the Speed Force obviously we
know on the TV show the negative Speed
Force the still force the sage force the
strength force and then they just
introduced one last year called the
forever force that'll all probably have
something to do with
black hole storyline they'll probably do
a vastly simplified version so if all
this different sage speed forever force
stuff seems kind of confusing don't
worry I don't think they're gonna do all
that stuff on the TV show but it is
really cool if you want to read that
comic book maybe they'll even bring back
the black flash because the black flash
was a big part of the death of the Speed
Force storyline everyone post all your
theories and your reactions in the
comments below obviously new flash next
week there was some really big black
Adam news so I might do a black Adam
Shazam video sometime soon I'll be
posting my non-spoilery Sonic the
Hedgehog movie review real soon too
while you wait for everything click here
for that brand new Avengers infinity
saga deleted scene with Thor and click
here for that brand new Spider Man
Marvel announcement they just made about
a mystery spider-man movie next year
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight
[Music]